benjamin is now the favored son
you other brothers go because there
could be some harm on the way
but don't let me lose my beloved son
so i'm going to begin in chapter 42
after joseph has read all of pharaoh's
dreams
after he's he's become a high-ranking
official
and now the brothers are about to come
to him this kind of
book-end narrative for the joseph story
chapter 42
and jacob saw that there were provisions
in egypt and jacob said to his sons
why are you fearful and he said look i
have heard that there are provisions in
egypt
go down there get us provisions from
there that we may live
and not die and the ten brothers of
joseph
went to buy grain from egypt but
benjamin
joseph's brothers jacob did not sin with
his brothers
for he thought lest harm befall him
benjamin is now the favored son he is
the new joseph to his brothers
you other brothers go because there
could be some harm on the way
but don't let me lose my beloved son the
son
of rachel and the sons of israel came to
buy provisions among those who came
for there was famine in the land of
canaan as for joseph he was regent of
the land
he was provider to all the people and
joseph brothers came and bowed down to
him and their faces to the ground
and joseph saw his brothers and
recognized them and he played the
stranger to them
and spoke harshly to them and he says
where have you come from
and just notice here what's going on
notice they bow down to the ground
and if you remember your details in the
text you know
this is specifically from joseph's
dreams
when all the sheaves bow down to joseph
now you're going to see this
same image of the bowing down repeated
again and again and again
and joseph recognized his brothers but
they did not recognize
him and joseph remembered the dreams he
had dreamed about them
and he said to them you are spies to see
the land's nakedness you have come
and they said to him no my lord for your
servants have come to buy food we are
all the sons of one man we are honest
your servants would never be spies and
he said to them no for the land's
nakedness you have come to see
and it's this weird accusation he makes
against them
you are spies but i want you to think
about
what how what does this have to do to
the previous episode that we've seen
that this second part of the joseph
story is a playing out of the first part
he needs them to see their misdeeds he
needs them to replay that drama one more
time
to get them to stop and to turn back
from their ways
to see their errors so why is he
accusing them of spies
i think it's simple enough is that not
what they accused joseph
of being when his father would send them
out to bring ill report
what is he accusing them of now he's
accusing them
of being spies it's a replay of that
first story
twelve brothers your servants are only
the sons of one man in the land of
canaan
and look the youngest is now with our
father and one is no more
and joseph said to them that's just what
i told you you are spies
you shall not leave this place unless
your youngest brother comes here
send one of you to bring your brother
and as for the rest of you you will be
detained and your words will be tested
as to whether the truth is with you
and if not by pharaoh you must be spies
and he put them under guard for three
days
and joseph said to them on the third day
do this and live for i fear god
if you were honest let one of your
brothers be detained in this very guard
house and the rest of you go forth and
bring back
provisions to stave off the famine in
your homes and your youngest brother you
shall bring to me
that your words may be confirmed and you
need not
die and they said each to his brother
alas we are guilty for our brother whose
mortal distress we saw when he pleaded
with us and we did not listen
that is why this distress has overtaken
us you can see what's going on here
the plan is working the brothers are
recognizing already
the way in which that which they had
done to joseph is coming to bear here
then reuben spoke out to them in these
words didn't i say to you do not sin
against the boy
and you would not listen and now look
his blood is requited
look it it's the same pattern here
remember the first story they all speak
together with one voice
then the first voice that singles
himself out is reuben it's the same
pattern repeated here they all speak
with one voice
then reuben speaks out one more time and
he even brings uh
brings out look his blood is requited
and of course
joseph recognizes all of the all of this
and he weeps and joseph gives orders
that they fill their bag with grain and
fill it
with silver and of course when the
brothers discover this
they're horrified now they'll be accused
of being spies be accused of being
thieves what joseph is kind of reminding
them of here
is what he was sold to in egypt
for for that money he's putting the
money right back into their bags is this
constant reminder
and of course they report to their
father everything that has transpired in
egypt
how now simeon is the one who's left
there and in order to get simeon back
there again has to be this exchange
there has to be a sacrifice
we must bring back benjamin in order to
bring back simeon
and israel's response is startling
jacob their father said to them me you
have bereaved joseph is no more
and simeon is no more and benjamin you
would take
it is i who bear all and reuben spoke to
his father
saying my two sons you may put to death
if i do not bring him back to you
place him in my hands and i will return
him to you and here again what do you
see
reuben working so hard to get back into
his father's graces
to really offer up something absurd yes
of course this will make israel feel
better if you don't bring him back
he's going to kill his two grandsons
ruben's so desperate to get back in his
father's
good graces what he's willing to say is
i'll sacrifice my two sons
on behalf of benjamin and of course this
isn't going to get anywhere
with israel and he said my son shall not
go down with you for his brother
is dead and look at this line and he
alone remains and think about all of the
brothers hearing this
benjamin alone remains i will not send
him with you
which essentially means i'll keep him
and simeon's just gonna have to stay
there in
egypt imagine what this is what these
brothers are witnessing here
all on behalf of benjamin and should
harm befall him on the way you were
going you would
bring down my gray head in sorrow
to shale it's the same repetition he
won't be consoled
you will bring my head down to shale in
this
in this sorrow it's a complete replay of
the joseph's story
and of course what we need to anticipate
now because of course we know
they will be going back to egypt and
they will be bringing
benjamin with them
thank you for watching we hope you're
enjoying our highlight series and
invite you to explore all of hillsdale
college's online courses
they are free and for everyone who loves
to learn